the lights are still on in London's
Theatreland but the audience is still at
home
the posters put up at the beginning of
lockdown in hindsight wildly optimistic
but after weeks of warnings from the
arts sector about its imminent demise
the curtains finally been lifted on what
the government will do to help a one and
a half billion pound Support Package it
hopes will stop these doors staying shut
for good it's fantastic news and also
not only is it fantastic news it's very
very welcome at this particular time in
this pandemic where the arts are
suffering so much pressure has been
building on the government to act
following a number of high-profile
campaigns but the helps come too late
for some Southampton's Nuffield theater
closed down last week and the playwright
James Graham fears more will follow with
a number of other cultural venues
reportedly on the brink of collapse
this week and it depending how people
can get this package we may see some
more Peter struggling next week but if
it's coming and it's as generous as it
as it sounds then it will make the world
of difference to keeping this this globe
or beating sector alive behind the doors
though there's still no life to speak of
guidance on when the show can go on
is expected to be published shortly as
welcome as this investment is there
still no concrete date as to when these
doors can reopen theatres like this that
are specifically designed to be intimate
enclosed spaces face real challenges in
meeting any social distancing guidelines
and so some within the industry are
questioning whether they will even be
able to open within the year the roads
recovery could still be quite long ahead
of us the truth is that what we've been
told by public health England is that
being in a confined space is dangerous
being close to other people is dangerous
singing is dangerous and dancing is
dangerous those are the four things on
which live music is built the Prime
Minister's interventionist policies have
taken center stage in his plan for
economic recovery the government today
also pumping a further 100 million
pounds into traineeships for young
people
where the arts are concerned it's a
welcomed twist in what seemed certain to
be a tragic tale but for now it's still
unclear when it'll all end Iver Bennett
Sky News